you got evicted on double eviction night
how are you feeling
i definitely feel overwhelmed i think
usually at any live eviction everyone is
kind of prepared of a 50 50 chance of
leaving and have a speech repaired but
for me it happened out of nowhere and it
happened with hannah who i thought was
my final two so i definitely feel feel
overwhelmed um it's still running
through my head things that i wish i
would have said in my speech and things
that i wish i would have done beforehand
but either way it was really cool to
experience a double eviction
you said you felt betrayed by hannah now
that you have had some time to sit with
it what are your feelings towards her
now
i don't take anything in this game
personally i really do want to see
hannah succeed in this game because i
feel like people do underestimate her
and she's a very very very intelligent
young woman
i will say i only feel betrayed because
i do think that
i really did believe her that she wanted
to have a final two with me maybe that
was the case and she didn't want to take
out x but i really did start gaining my
trust with her and i always looked out
for her in this game
is there something you wish you had done
differently during the game
i don't regret anything i did in this
game i think the difference with this
season is that no matter when you think
you're aligned with that person and you
want to be an honest and loyal player
like i was wanting to be this whole
season people stabbed you in the back
then next week so it was definitely
ruthless this season for me i tried to
be i tried to be myself and be honest
and loyal and that didn't get me to the
end but it got me to top seven and i'm
happy with that
do you think will go far in this game
and who do you want to go for in this
game
i think that hannah and kylan are in a
very
i think hannah and kylian are a very
good position in this house to go far in
the game i think people underestimate
hannah and the fact that kylan was able
to get big d and aza to vote me out over
him he probably isn't a good position
and i really want to see xavier go far
in this game
for the first time ever big brother will
have a winner who is black
do you have a reaction to being a part
of this historic season
i am so honored to be a part of such a
historic season i realized this going in
knowing that claire may be going home
that the top seven are people of
minority and to think that a black
winner is going to happen this season
makes me so happy my nephews are half
black and to be part of a historic
season um i'm very grateful that i get
to cast that vote